irene khan et aux copeaux voyage sans
passeport cette émission est réalisée
avec le concours de michel angot 10 aux
lancers faire montage sont bonnes ça
reste son jean charest illustration
sonore denise glaser san francisco
grandes villes gratte ciel
une femme anne elle est par dessus le
vent du pacifique
rue abrupte au long desquels se hisse
les câbles ce quart
villes chinoises si importante qu'elle a
son réseau téléphonique pop
golden gate gigantesque plan leed
il enjambe la baie de san francisco tout
près du mexique san diego
bord de guerre aux commerces et aux six
stations balnéaires
habillé de caoutchouc parce que la mer
est froide ils vont chercher les
poissons
oh vous le ce rivage le long du
pacifique au bout vers l'ouest a while
hawaï et lycée dautet l'ultramoderne
honolulu les cocotiers d'honolulu semble
n'être que des motifs décoratifs
tout y est plus américain que polynésien
pour retrouver le charme d'hawaï
il faut quitter honolulu et aller vers
les autres îles de l'archipel
ici l'on retrouve un véritable paradis
terrestre
palétuviers
cocotiers calme reposant db transparente
le long des grèves les enfants enjouée
chercher des poissons multicolores
poisson étranges poissons comme boisson
papilles aux poissons et aux vieux
pourquoi pas le long des grèves on
rencontre aussi des pélicans et quelques
proches
partout aussi des fleurs
vous gagnez shower prix ils sont pète
allongé grève
pervenche et la sensible au moindre
contact elle se replie sur elle même
abandonnée morte elle ne reprendra vie
que quelques heures plus tard
oui
des fougères tapissent les parois et
humide les cascades sont fréquentes et
ligne de canaille possède un camion
intérieur
à travers les bancs de brouillard en b
contre le bleu profond de l'océan qui
vient battre ces rivages escarpés des
sauvages
c'est à la base des montagnes près de la
mer que se trouvent les régions cultiver
verger de pas paye déjà lu les étreint
les fruits sont accrochés au tronc de
l'arbre
et tout en effet paquereau battre pour
reccueillir principale richesse des îles
hawaï
la plantation de canne à sucre le cam
sont très haut au moment de leur école
alors on y met le feu
les feuilles brûle tandis que gorges et
jeff sucre et les canucks un pare feu
il ne reste plus qu'à ramasser litiges
sans avoir à élaguer les feuilles
non
ces cultures d'un alain sont très
importantes
celui ci et là namur et deux autres ne
l'étaient pas la récolte les fruits se
fait à l'aide de cette machine
cependant il est de bon ton de se
retrouver un jour ou l'autre à honolulu
et d'y vivre dans un farniente continue
les maisons ils descendent jusqu'au bord
de la mer et leurs propriétaires push la
paresse jusqu'à se construire des barres
flottant pourquoi pas il profite aussi
beaucoup de la plage de waikiki
le surf riding sport polynésien et a été
annexé par les américaines c'est venu
jusqu'en france
c'est particulièrement difficile
non
au nom des pirogues à balancier
on fait de la voile enfin je suis
discret
à leur descente d'avion ou à leur départ
les personnalités sont salués par des
groupes folkloriques
il est étrange de voir ces jolies filles
dansaient sur le ciment la moins pourra
le supporter des peuples mais il faut
aussi quitté hawaï important sur les
ailes de l'avion ce mot alors qui
signifie je t'aime pour doigt ou plus
simplement pour enfin